[Music]
so you guys know how
dna kits are like really popular these
are like 23andme
i just did one which one did you do i
did 23 in me like two months ago
and what'd you find out uh apparently i
have nothing wrong with me so that's
really nice oh it's good well what about
the culture though that's more important
you find that part
found out that i uh my corsican side is
not french it's actually spanish
so that's cool oh cool did that take
away a slice of your of your feeling of
your identity
no i mean i i found out that my family
was actually like part
corsican like a few years ago already
what's corsican
so it's like an island that france owns
in the mediterranean
oh but it's like kind of near like italy
so it's a bunch of better training
people
they live there so you're part
vietnamese part spanish
yeah apparently yeah so that's pretty
cool congrats
yeah thank you i appreciate it but then
uh the thing that
did ease my mind was the i wanted to
really find out my health kit stuff
and i had none of the uh none of the
markings for like any of the bad stuff
like alzheimer's and stuff so
that's good kind of boring though you
know i was like oh what do i have
nothing
okay i guess yeah yeah
i know they even picked up that diabetes
runs in my family
wow i better check mine it changes too
it changes because i was uh 98
japanese and one percent korean yeah and
then when i checked again it was 99
japanese so i couldn't i'm not i wasn't
korean anymore
we probably we're just reading way more
missing isn't that
they don't give you a hundred you're
probably reading way more about japanese
history which i know you you're probably
doing and it changed it yeah it changed
a little bit
in my ancestry thing i could see exactly
where japan attacked asia because i
could see a little bit of me that's
japanese that's time i'm like
that part of my family is japanese you
guys you weren't in love
no no that sucks yeah sure i was around
world war
ii i know what happened there there's
also like a
a feature where you can make it like
more intense or
light lighter or whatever to see your
your country thingies i remember messing
with that
where it's like more accurate or like
because they changed their algorithm
like
a year ago or something right you can
see what it was before the algorithm
change
and now so now it's much more specific
but when you click the before it's like
boom spread out like it's it shows that
you're from all these different
countries that you're not from
okay i like my intense like the
historical fact like
you were a product of incest or like
something like no
like they're gonna sugarcoat it like
it's less intense it shows where what
your family is from which is cool it
shows like what cities in vietnam my
family
is from from my dna that's cool really
yeah mine too
it says like jalisco like that i gotta
check that [ __ ] out
it's been a minute yeah i'm worried
about doing it because i'll be like from
incest royalty or something
with european history and all you know
you never know and floridian history
but yeah so the whole family's from so i
have this
this video here of this girl named kat
and she's from nashville tennessee and
so
she's explaining her story
which we actually don't have an ending
but we have up to this point so i'm
gonna let
you guys check out her story
can anyone else take an ancestry dna
test and accidentally
uncover a family suit okay
i got a story for you my dad came up
with the brilliant idea of giving the
entire family
ancestry dna kids last year for
christmas i too have identified as irish
because
my last name is mcdonald and my hair is
bright turns out
i'm 75 norwegian and the rest is like
german and british and there's zero
irish
i found this out on saint patty's day so
i called him cracking up saying guess
what
i'm not irish at all he calls me at ten
o'clock which we all know is like three
a.m dad time saying
there's no way you're not irish so with
my dad
on the phone i log into my account to
see if i have any dna matches
and i had an exact paternal match it
just wasn't him i confronted my mom and
two of my aunts immediately
everyone including my mother was shook
but even my dad recognized the name
apparently he was an
old family friend so i love this dude's
name
and he's a billionaire he's the ceo for
a major company and his three
daughters work for him and naturally
like the unstable millennial that i am i
drive halfway across the country to his
corporate office
i tried to give him a letter but when he
heard my name he refused to meet with me
basically all it said was thank you
because i'm really happy to be alive
she had a lot of wine yeah you saw that
tall that glass yeah
it was shrinking it was shrinking the
person that she's implying
are we all supposed to know who's
billionaire is i know it's a billionaire
redhead though
who's a billionaire that has three nah
he's one for him
i think donald trump has two um in the
car
i watched this but in the comments they
mentioned but he's one
unfamiliar i don't know this billionaire
he's not like a super common guy
you saw this because it was all
tick-tock yeah yeah mr billiam what's a
billionaire gender
i know i know right they're usually poor
yeah they don't make it i know because
he didn't want to have anything to do
with her so i'm like damn that's crazy
but he wants to have everything to do
with his three other daughters maybe
because there's
rapport there's always when you're a
billionaire everyone's like i'm related
yeah right well no i actually yeah you
are probably my daughter but it's been
some time now you know how many
daughters come in here every [ __ ]
10 days you know how many got
taken out he probably [ __ ] a lot of
girls come on he's he's a billionaire
damn you know how much horn i'd be doing
what if he just said
um so how much do i owe you
she's like wait i just wanted a
connection goes no man my time is way
more valuable than that
damn we also at the end of that second
tick tock she ended up saying that she
there could be a potential
part three to this story so who knows
where he could lead but i'm actually
really curious to know like
what happened with her mom and her dad
what happened with her family friend i
mean he doesn't know her
she had to drive all the way out there
and [ __ ] get thrown out by security
sounds like he knew about her
oh you oh i see let's see her get out of
here yeah exactly so i think the
billionaire friend knew that she existed
didn't want anything to do with her but
i'm curious to find out like
how did the mom [ __ ] tell the
the dad yeah i want to know that
conversation well they might have been
divorced on the converse
i could just go to [ __ ] like i don't
know uh
jeff bezos's place right now and be like
jeff it's steve green i'm your son
daddy and then right and then he's like
once i heard the name i'm like
[ __ ] off it's not my son and then i'm
like once he heard the name
that's when he asked me to leave see
yeah like it doesn't it doesn't jive to
me oh yeah
it's not that way it doesn't work that
way or because she said she had a letter
yeah so then why would she just announce
i'm your daughter no i believe that she
i believe her yeah
you mean i thought that was a letter she
wrote that she wanted to give to him
yeah but it's just like hey i'm i'm this
person there's i have a letter
and i don't have to announce i'm the
daughter i believe her i just think he
put his dna
out there and he's just like he came in
a he cream pie i don't remember
he's on ancestry.com already too where
it's like did you not
expect this to happen oh right i feel
like ancestry.com
is opening up and ruining a lot of
secrets good cause like my on my dad's
side
on my dad's side uh his
oldest brother who's passed away now i
remember when i first went to go visit
his
side in china um my dad's like you see
his uh his daughter that's not really
his or theirs
i'm like what happened well they adopted
um
because like i guess they couldn't
conceive or something and then i'm like
why are you telling me this because i
felt like i was like this
10 year old that's has to like hold on
to this giant secret you actually
have he's gossiping with your 10 year
old ass you actually asked why are you
telling me this because that's a 10 year
old
inside in my brain i was that's what i
was thinking and then i was like
and then i'm like have you told anyone
else or does anyone else know right now
and my dad's like no no one knows you
have to keep it a secret okay
like when i have family dinners i'm just
looking at it like you're not part of
our family
after this during dinner was your dad
like so funny
he's such a [ __ ] prankster when i go
home and i tell my mom my mom's like oh
yeah
that's uh she she was adopted
and i'm like what the [ __ ] i'm like i
thought she doesn't know but then now
your dad knows that you can't keep a
secret yeah
oh he doesn't watch the show but it's
too late and i'm like but if they
start he doesn't watch the show this
show doesn't understand
but if they he i don't try and translate
he likes the vlogs
he does like the vlog you got scared
immediately it doesn't work but yeah if
they all do the ancestry.com stuff then
all these secrets will start coming out
all right
i don't know i find that my mom watches
the show a little bit because she's like
i'm not that much of a hoarder and i'm
like that's what a hoarder would
say
but she like i am fine though that's my
sister
my sister doesn't want she's enough but
does your mom get uncomfortable
with you making comments about your
sister being hot she knows my sister's a
[ __ ] dime
[Laughter]
she made her but yeah i don't know
it's so interesting i kind of want to
know more like family drama with
this lady what's going on with your life
that's why you need to download tick
tock
no don't make it rent convince me to
download tick tock again why have you
made tick tock so interesting to me i
was
ready to leave it behind you don't have
tick tock no tik tok is amazing
my wife got addicted to it for like nine
days and i didn't even see her it's one
of the funnest things that me and joe do
before we go to bed
we we put the phone and lean it against
the pillow
we used to watch tv shows but now we
just lay there and we just scroll
through tick-tock is that right
yeah and you both agree on one phone on
one phone because i don't have to talk
on the algorithm i mean we both kind of
like the same weird stuff
so we just kind of like snap pop dancing
so just i don't know it's just like all
right what are you guys watching um
there'll be ones about like
some of them are really dumb some of
them will like they could tell your
future
in like 30 seconds so some of them are
really dumb how does that work
the fortune telling globe or whatever it
is yeah it's a mobile phone but
it's just you put a picture you post it
but then they're like
oh my god you know the reaction is like
so good that you're like
okay cool yeah and some of them it's
like an animal taking care of another
animal
yeah those are awesome i like that [ __ ]
i like that and then some of them it's
like
best house mix 20 20 and you're like oh
those are good house jams
before bed though no yeah guessed you
too high
it's so random and it's cool yeah yeah i
would lay in bed and then my girlfriend
she used to like
be really into tick-tock so then like
you can't ignore it because she's just
like laughing at random [ __ ] right next
to my ear and i'm like
open open let me see too and we're just
both watched together and she's going
through
and sometimes something's interesting
but she passed i'm like no no go back go
back come back yeah yeah
that is funny dude that's why like
instagram pretty much is tick tock now
because they just repost tik tok so
that's why i'm like no i don't need the
app
i already got it i already got it
because instagram is late
you're on time and you're with it
instagram is like one week later it's
okay i can be late it's all right you
know demographics wise it is that it's
like i think
instagram is a late millennial to
whatever the generation is above that
and then i think tick tock is
gen z yeah gen z don't even use
instagram like my nephews
none of them use instagram yeah you can
read in the comments instagram is dying
instagram people instagram snapchat and
then tick tock snapchat is in the middle
it blows my mind how do you guys share
stuff with each other like
because then tick tock you're creating
content you know so i'm like how do you
just share your life with each other
they i guess they just do these got
kicked out of school my mom beat my ass
well isaac got a phone for his birthday
now that he's
13. kind of phony oh you got my old
iphone
oh hey that's tight though iphone 10 in
my old apple watch dude
that to him is a brand new like no and i
kept it really nice so it is practically
brand new
no cracks on the screen hero cracks in
pristine condition
happy he's like yeah he cried it was so
he was he cried so go check it out
she that's cute yeah it's super cute so
it was an intimate moment and we have a
vlog you gotta go check it out
no i mean it was we did like a little
party birthday thingy don't skip the ad
breaks you pricks
yeah you [ __ ] let me get to the
point so he has a phone now i told him
you can have social media now that
you're 13.
which one but uh just make sure it's
private and
i have to follow you and i got to know
what you're doing i got to be a good
parent
um and so he only has tick tock on his
phone
he doesn't he didn't download anything
oh she can't follow me this way
she doesn't even have the app she
doesn't know that he knows dancing girls
that i watch
the gram is for boomers i don't know i
didn't ask him but
i actually don't want to ask him like
are you gonna get an instagram because i
kind of don't want to push him to get
one
does he think we're cool like does he
think i'm cool
no does he have trailer or prowler we're
late
but like no i know that you like you in
case you're lame but the republican one
what's the republican instagram parlor
parliament
stupid i gotta get my right-wing news
stupid
no but it's so cute though but because i
don't have tick tock oh so he
sends me links to the videos he likes or
he's constantly like if you look at our
our
like chat it's all tick tock videos and
so i'm constantly
on tick tock but not on tik tok i only
see it through the safari
man that's tight i can't wait till i can
like have conversation with tyka like
i love it just texting him it's so fun
and then we facetime it's so cute that's
how i feel about my kid brother i have a
i have a kid brother who's like my baby
brother
like i remember changing his diapers and
[ __ ] what is he like 28 or something
yeah he's like seven years younger than
me so he's like literally like [ __ ]
35 you know
but but no but um like talking to him
and like sending him memes and [ __ ] and
talking about [ __ ]
and like sometimes he posts gifs he's
like i'm literally coming to this
because it's like crypto [ __ ] or
whatever
and i'm like i see that i just remember
him as a child and i'm like this is so
weird and yet so funny at the same time
yeah
yeah it's weird how it all changes
that's true tyson has the most
boring conversation
you